who are the top five defenses that you
face you know who presents the most
adversity whenever you plan them that
Denver team is one of the best defenses
I played against going against the team
yeah when y'all won the Super Bowl it's
like Akeem to lead Chris Harris Chris
Harris Seattle was a tough task back
then like you know how good that yeah
Richard Sherman and all that all those
guys I was like this damn like a prom a
prom Pastor Peterson is really still one
of the best DBS to ever play the game uh
Kansas City obviously presumes some type
of difficulty because they do so many
different things and I'm saying if they
trying to take you out of the game this
is like as a receiver it's possible you
know I'm saying you can do whatever you
can to try to get the ball
um and having that offensive mind and
those OCS it really helps yeah but uh
Casey is obviously one of the good
defenses I thought La was a good team
too I was over there with them boys like
I didn't I knew that's why I kept saying
like don't blink don't blink because at
any given moment they can be right back
100